and uh for juju smith schuster it's 18
minus the teen
it's one year 8 million to stay
what to stay yeah with the pittsburgh
steelers
uh and this is just a week after nfl
media said he was telling teammates he's
not going to come back to pittsburgh
it's barely a week after he voted on
that si.com poll
will juju stay in pittsburgh either i
hope so or that's a negative and there
he is blue checkmark
juju that's a negative so he
he he uh hey he thought he was gonna get
much bigger money yeah in the open
market we talked about it last week it
was crickets with juju's miss schuster
and it worked out just perfectly and
chris it came down to
the steelers and the ravens
it was steelers and it was ravens there
was a report the eagles were involved
that was a lie there's a report the
chiefs got involved they got involved
late it was too late to change
the momentum at that point it was down
to two choices
steelers eight million ravens
nine million plus three and a half
million in incentives
juju opted to stay where he had spent
the first four years of his career and
go back to the team
that a week ago he was certain he was
leaving
that to me was a stunning outcome chris
that's stunning i mean it really is
well again it just speaks to the wide
receiver market like we were talking
about
i mean it really does at least with
kenny galladay you know last week we
heard
teams you know being associated with him
a little bit and
talked about juju like you said was
nothing it was like man i don't know
what's gonna happen i haven't even heard
like the slightest rumor of connecting
him with anybody
other than the jet the jets that was the
one you kind of heard about
right and here's what happened yeah we
talk on thursday
where's juju there's nobody on juju
there's no reports
and and then all of a sudden oh somebody
leaks to nfl media that the jets are
interested well where was that before 8
a.m on thursday uh-huh
so they were getting they were getting
there was a lot of heat there was a lot
of heat on the agents
and look i think what happened he went
into it wanting too much
once more teams knew what he wanted they
all shied away from him
they had to let him reduce his
expectations on his own
it seemed that way i mean it certainly
like the writing was on the wall as far
as that and i mean unless all you got to
do is look at what he signed for
that pretty much tells you exactly what
was out there to be had he didn't go oh
you know oh i had 15 million dollars a
year or 14 million a year on the
on the market but i'm gonna i'm gonna
take one year nine million with
pittsburgh no
that means there was nothing in the
range of what juju was expecting
listen this is i'm interested to see how
this plays out i understand his decision
but it was risky versus risky to me
either way
you know you go to baltimore yeah it
could be cool
you know you might win the afc north and
you know be a part of a great football
team and all that
but as we know you might come away with
a year where the stats are just
meh like man they're not that great
because they run the ball and yeah you
might have some cool highlight plays but
he's gonna really have the reception
and yards to back it up now he goes to
pittsburgh mike
and i'd say i don't know i still think
it's risky
he's risky going to pittsburgh too i
mean i think it's a roll of the dice
we discussed last week i mean i'd have a
hard time thinking that the steelers
coaches didn't go back last year watch
film and go whoa
we got to get claypool and deontay
johnson the baltimore
like you know that that that to me would
be like the thing
they're gonna look at and go they're
difference makers juju is really good
but those two guys can scare defenses
and do things like that
so juju i think is also taking a risk of
not being able to have a huge
statistical year there
either but either way it's a place where
he's comfortable at
he's got a role in the offense and i
understand that and he's going to try to
make it work and i'm rooting for him
i wonder how much any of this matters to
the guy who actually makes the decisions
in real time to throw the football
and to whom he will be throwing the
football because
even though i agree with you yeah they
need to build the offense around
claypool and johnson
he sees juju out there and he is ben
roethlisberger
is he going to feel like a loyalty is he
going to feel like he
like hey he took less to come back here
and be with me
my final season in pittsburgh i just
wonder whether or not that's going to
influence the quarterback at some level
he's the guy who's pulling the trigger
remember brett favre all those years ago
when javon walker was trying to get more
money and was threatening to hold out
far was like hey
i'm the one who decides who gets the
football buddy and we know that's the
way it goes chris you've lived it you
know that that can creep into the
mindset of a quarterback
i just can't help but wonder whether or
not having juju around
is going to potentially potentially keep
the offense from being what it can be
because ben may feel compelled to throw
it to him well
ben's definitely going to have a uh
there's a comfort level with juju
i i don't doubt that at all i don't now
you know i i where i'm surprised i guess
mike
more than anything is you know i just
thought maybe we'd see the
the steelers try to change how they're
gonna play a little bit right we you
know we've talked about that
smash mouth football you know protect
the quarterback
two and three man routes do that you
know maybe
start getting a fullback involved and
leading a smash mouth tail back in
between the tackles that type of stuff
and i thought maybe we might see them
get away from
three wide receiver sets a little bit to
where it's more two tight end sets and
two receivers with one back and
you know one tight end you know a a full
back of tailback and two receivers i
thought we might see some of that
just from them just to change the way
they play and like we've talked about so
much follow the brady tampa bay method
let's play defense let's run the ball a
little bit let's protect the quarterback
let's let him dice up one-on-one
coverage um
you know three receivers on the field of
course that tells me maybe they're going
to be a little bit still of a drop back
pass football team
either way but it's an affordable price
nine million dollars for juju smith
schuster one year
their team they probably look at
themselves in the super bowl winner go
ahead go do it
and give big ben the weapons he needs to
to make something happen
and again it's 8 million not nine nine
every million counts for a team like the
steelers that is up against the cap
they did four avoidable years on the
back end the cap number ends up being
2.4 million but that was still enough
to put the steelers in a situation where
they have to trade cornerback stephen
nelson
now because you need to have caps base
to sign your draft picks
so nelson's out because smith schuster's
back it's that simple
and from the ravens perspective they
looked at it as i understand it in a
very simple way
either we're going to get this guy or
we're going to screw the steelers up
a little bit more from their cap
standpoint because if they
bring juju back they're going to have to
get rid of somebody else they want to
keep
so it was a a win either way for
baltimore but what it does underscore
chris is the difficulty of convincing
players who catch footballs for a living
sure
to make their living in a place where
they may not be catching footballs yeah
no i think that's you know it's a real
thing with the baltimore
ravens it comes down to that you know i
think you're
we're gonna continue to see that if it's
a
you know this for that situation i'm
between a
and b i think the ravens are one of
those teams that
yeah i mean for a wide receiver they're
probably going to have to pay
a little bit more to make a guy switch a
team
or or you know go to a go to go come
here to baltimore where yes it might not
be statistically as comfortable as the
other
options you have and they might have to
pay a little premium for that because of
the style they play on the offensive
side of the ball i don't deny that one
bit
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports